en maintenant la direction d'orléans je
vous le disais en titre fin mars une
dizaine de jeunes en valeur de kiev
étaient accueillis chez nous grâce au
club de saint jean de blanc saint denis
en val depuis ces jeunes sportifs
s'entraînent cinq fois par semaine avec
le club et leur arrivée a quelque peu
bousculé les habitudes à l'entraînement
il a d'abord fallu s'adapter au niveau
très élevé des ukrainiens et surtout
apprendre à communiquer malgré la
barrière de la langue christine launay
et pierre dominique lovey
c'est le premier entraînement de la
semaine pour les jeunes handballeurs
ukrainien accueilli il y à un peu plus
d'un mois par le club de saint denis en
val
c'est une vraie chance pour nous nous
nous entraînons et nous sommes loin de
la guerre
c'est merveilleux
[Musique]
on se sent bien ici c'est un plaisir
d'être ici si nous étions en ukraine ce
ne serait pas bien pour nous parce qu'on
resterait toute la journée à la maison
le club leur dispense cinq entraînements
par semaine alexander is not possible to
shoot
légué
un entraînement traduit en anglais et
adaptées aux très hauts niveaux des
handballeurs destiné à jouer dans
l'équipe nationale ukrainienne
sélectionneur est venu
on a vu on les a vus travailler
différemment et répéter et répéter
encore et encore des gammes toujours des
gars même chose alors que nous en france
on défend la lecture de jeux sur la
circulation de balle pas de contact ok
non non et non
grata passe de mars ok la première des
choses qu'ils apportent c'est que en
fait ils sont
gérés que son ode off c'est à dire que
quand ils sont à l'entraînement qui sont
à 150 % et ils savent pas ils savent pas
s'économiser font pas 30% 40% comme on a
des fois un peu l'habitude de le voir
sur des catégories plus jeunes et pas
dans une logique de performance ça c'est
donc c'est très agréable quand on est
entraîneur parce que au moins n'a pas
besoin de relancer pour le club qui joue
en départementale la présence des jeunes
ukrainiens c'est du bonus elle permet de
maintenir l'effectif des joueurs et un
entraînement de très bon niveau jusqu'à
la fin de la saison